there's one thing about portland that
[Applause]
you guys have the most
arrogant
bicyclists i have
ever [ __ ]
[ __ ] those [ __ ] [ __ ] them [ __ ] [ __ ]
those bucks
yo yo
i'm in a [ __ ] car right on a car
[Applause]
i'm in a car
[Applause]
right so i'm in an uber and i say
there's a bicyclist
doing 20 in front of us
and i'm i turn to the guy i'm like
and he just goes
[Applause]
so i go you
you're gonna honk at him
you know what he said to me he goes just
like this
he's gonna be mad
[Applause]
and i was like who [ __ ] cares he was
like have you ever seen these guys mad
before
[Applause]
i go well presently i am paying you for
this ride
i would enjoy us to go more than [ __ ]
20.
[Applause]
because i'm tripping and i need to get
to the nike store
[Applause]
but i'm like honk i'll i'll handle with
whatever happens right
so yeah
he and he doesn't he's not like he
doesn't but
he just gives this dude a bam
my man on his [ __ ] my you know
on his bicycle goes just like this
[Applause]
i'm on my bike
[Applause]
and i was like
he [ __ ] comes back and he
raps on the window i'm like
and he goes
you got to watch out for bikers
and i go hey first of all bro
you're not a biker
[Music]
[Applause]
you ride a bicycle man you know a biker
has a leather vest and a [ __ ]
teardrop tattoo because he kills
somebody
[Applause]
you got spandex shorts and a [ __ ]
kale smoothie get the [ __ ] out of the
way
the uber driver said to me he goes
i've never seen anyone talk to one of
them like that
one of them like he's one of the walking
dead like
he's a grown-up in spandex shorts you
should be able to say whatever the [ __ ]
you want
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]